i hate intros log horizon season 2
episode 1.
we kicked things off with all the side
characters enjoying an after halloween
party in akihabara
meanwhile shiro is in negotiations with
a group called the cooney clan the kuni
clan are the ones that control
all of the banks as well as the flow of
money in the land they are also
responsible for deploying the royal
guards and maintaining the barriers that
keep the city safe from monsters
we drop in on the meeting where we meet
a new face in king joe
who refuses to negotiate with shiro
because of an ancient treaty the problem
he's trying to figure out is that the
roundtable have run into maintenance
fees the roundtable had purchased the
guild building cathedral and trade
building along with other facilities to
ensure that enemies of the roundtable
couldn't use those against them
the downside to this is that it's
costing the round table 10 million gold
a month in maintenance fees and they're
gonna go broke soon this information is
of course kept secret to prevent plant
who yadem from finding out the goblin
king event is still going on and the
adventures had began their invasion of
the main goblin camp at seventh vault
krusty and isaac are there serving as
the commanders in the assault kerosene
and agnea went along also for technical
and logistical support gero goes on to
inform vlog horizon members that he has
to leave
the city for a bit to find a solution to
their financial problems natsuki decides
he's going to tag along and akatsuki
wants to go also but shiro makes her
stay behind for a special job that he
has
while attacking with natsugu he reveals
his plan of making around 80 trillion
gold
reagan had also gone with him and all of
them meet with king joe shiro was
looking for king joe to give him a loan
which he's still against when monsters
are killed they drop gold and when they
respawn they have more gold shiro and
reagan figured that the gold has to be
coming from somewhere and they managed
to find the source
in the depths of pom there is said to be
a whirlpool filled with all of the gold
in the land
they managed to find the dungeon where
it's being kept but it's sealed away
with magic
shiro tells kincho that if they're not
willing to give him a loan then he'll be
forced to take it from there
this of course entails that he would be
stealing from the kuni clan which is
something shiro would rather not do
and why he's in negotiations with king
joe at the conclusion of their top king
joe tells them to meet him at the
meandering river and the forgotten
underground garden which is where the
coins appear and disappear into the void
kenjo says that this is a challenge for
shiro and his friends to clear a raid
quest in the depths of pom
if they can do this then they'll have
proven themselves to the kuni clan and
their request will be considered
since planet hooyating could be watching
the round table members they can't rely
on them to help now we jump ahead a bit
where we find that akatsuki and shiro
are on the moon
after having been killed for the first
time
needing members to fill out their raid
party shiro and the others head to
sousakino which they haven't been to
since rescuing sarah six months ago
once there he meets up with the silver
swords guild leader in william who had
walked out on the round table in season
one he tells him that they need a full
raiding party of 24 members to clear a
new raid
william is surprisingly eager to help
but the problem is that he doesn't have
enough men willing to fight in serious
raids anymore some of them had retired
due to encountering some sort of
phenomenon that happens when you die
during their conversation the dick cat
demi cost interrupts them meanwhile
natsugu and reagan go looking for help
also where they come across a new face
in tetra
she's kind of [ __ ] obnoxious but she
is a level 92 so they employ her for
help back to dumbass demi
kossu tries picking a fight with shiro
but that gets put to an end when natsugu
and tetra come in we learned that lawn
dark who was the lead strategist and
brigandia had given up on demi cost
because he got his ass kicked by shiro
and went out west
after that brigandia was then beaten by
the silver swords so they wound up just
joining them
anyways demikaz and tetra are added to
the rating party giving them enough
members to go through with it they fight
their way to the dungeon giving
everybody a chance to figure out their
roles in their group muriel and natsugu
have been getting closer and are both
confirmed into each other so keep an eye
on that
uh kotsuki was left behind in akihabara
in order to protect princess lenesia the
writing party finally arrives at the
entrance to the lowest level of the
depths of palm
and in the last scene we see that demi
cost still has a grudge against shiro
and wants to prevent him from getting
whatever it is he's after
episode 3. the raiding party is making
good time throughout the zone and
eventually run into their first raid
boss in vandemir
this turns out to be too much for them
and it forces them to retreat after
their strategy is dismantled
even after multiple attempts they kept
failing but in the process we're mapping
out its attack patterns once they have
learned its cooldown timers and how to
counter its most powerful moves they
finally succeeded in defeating it
these dungeons have multiple raid bosses
though bringing them to their second
challenge in
el reyda of the fifth prison after
around a dozen attempts they defeat that
one also they're now three weeks into
the raid and can't seem to find the
third boss
that's not the only problem though as
their supplies are dwindling because of
weapon and armor maintenance shiro
figures that they have around 20 days to
complete it before they run out of
materials
over to nyanta and the others who
discuss skill ranks
there are four ranks to skills in basic
adept hidden and secret
all of these ranks have different
prerequisites that you need in order to
learn them
in the novus fear pioneers expansion a
new rank was also added
above secret called teachings episode
4. everybody's getting excited because
there's only five days until christmas
we get some fan service filler content
and then we see that akatsuki has been
going to a shop because there was a
sword that she was wanting to buy
unfortunately the shopkeeper working
there tatara amanoma informs her that
she had just sold the sword to a man we
see that akatsuki is obsessing over
becoming more powerful
she goes to watch ddd assassins sparring
in hopes of seeing them use one of the
new teachings minori also pisses her off
because she thinks minori is more
valuable to shiro than she is
all of these self-conscious thoughts are
weighing on her so she wants to become
more powerful to be more useful to shiro
we also get a look at kyoko who is a
member of the west wind brigade
she gets confronted by a new character
in embarnals
he attacks stabs and kills her in the
last scene without any response from the
royal guards
episode 5. she wasn't the only victim
though as this mystery man has been
going around killing multiple
adventurers
on the night before christmas eve
another group of high-ranking honesty
members are attacked and slain by embar
also roundtable members in akihabara
have a meeting to discuss what to do
about this new enemy
they decide on evacuating lower level
members so people under level 50 are
told to go to xan leap to keep them safe
akatsuki still wanting to get stronger
is out looking for the killer by herself
westwind had also sent out groups to
find and deal with embark who eventually
run into him meanwhile king joe had
stopped by for an unexpected visit with
lenesia
he informs her that one of the royal
guard's armor has been stolen from the
guard house
the culprit was embark who was a member
of the royal guard as well as the cooney
clan
there is a massive magic circle under
every city that powers the royal guard's
armor so technically he can't leave the
city
however while he's in the city he's
nearly invincible and way stronger than
any adventurer
they could always disable the circle and
cut off the supply of magic to the armor
but doing that would allow monsters to
attack the city
on top of that the circle and the
barrier would take decades to boot up
again okotsky talks with lynnetti about
the situation and tells her that it's
likely embar is hiding in the sewers we
can't just go down and kill him though
because the royal guard armor allows him
to teleport anywhere he wants in the
city so
jiro catches up with the other west wind
members fighting mbar but they can't
even deal damage to him when the two
start fighting
we learn that sojuro has a teaching
ability called divine eye
this allows him to see the path an
opponent is going to use to attack
that doesn't really help and he still
gets his ass handed to him but akatsuki
had to come across him and joins the
fight so
jira kind of knew from the start that
they were going to lose and he was just
buying time for his guild members to
escape what's ever gone he gives
akatsuki some big advice on how to get
her teaching rank which was essentially
try harder for head and then gets killed
we get a quick scene of shira and the
raiding party getting [ __ ] on in the
dungeon and in the last scene akatsuki
dies
episode 6. over to kotsuki who is now
dead and has some cryptic vision of when
she was in the real world
she realizes that when she was living
there she was moving forward but didn't
really have a goal in mind
suddenly she wakes up on some sort of
beach who were surprised shiro shows up
shortly after
the two of them are forced to give up a
memory in exchange for being able to
revive
once back akatsuki begs nasana and rize
to share their teachings with her so
that she can try and defeat embar again
over to rodrik who is teaching a class
where he explains that men who have
female characters will slowly take on
more feminine characteristics such as a
voice change
he also tells his class that for some
unknown reason the world's geography is
slowly growing to a larger scale
next they go over flavor text and how
they were originally designed to have no
effect on gameplay
ever since the apocalypse that has
changed and now the flavor text is
influencing the world in different ways
in his conclusion roderick says that the
world is undergoing some sort of
transformation and the apocalypse isn't
over yet
then we hop on over to krusty who is
with the cutie chan in misa
as the two of them go out to look for
some goblins to slay misa's weapon has
some ominous flavor text that they've
never really thought about
bad idea because it starts going haywire
on misa so krusty pushes her to safety
and gets caught up by the weapon instead
the weapon makes krusty disappear
and misa had lost an arm trying to get
to him
episode 7 henrietta and risay go to meet
with yet another new character in the
blonde named mikage
she informs them that all of the flavor
tanks are manifesting itself into
reality this is bad news because embar
is using the grapple sword of yakumaru
the sword used to belong to a man named
rugrius who was turned into a monster
mercurius was an izumo knight who
protected susquino from
giants the maiden of elm named sutu
inaud betrayed him by poisoning his
drink which killed him
afterwards he became a monster filled
with hatred for everybody he's out for
vengeance against all the humans because
of the [ __ ] that killed him
over to embark who shows that the flavor
text had created the spirit of rugrious
and now it's possessing him
meanwhile akatsuki trains with ddd
members to try and learn her first
teaching skill
reese fills the round table and on the
fact that the sword gives embark stat
buffs for each person fighting him
within 50 meters
to counter this resay suggests having a
raid inside the city with a 24-man team
and instead of having six-man groups
like normal they will only
have two or three people in each group
and spread them across the city
they also plan to have lenesia shot off
the magic circle which would cut off the
powers of the armor
turns out the sword that akatsuki was
wanting to buy was actually bought by
embark so she kind of dodged a bullet
there tatara is feeling guilty about
selling the sword to embark but is
consoled for her colossal fuck-up irises
akatsuki had failed trying to learn a
teaching technique but is still
optimistic that they're gonna win
on new year's eve all the teams head out
to fight and bart and in the last scene
akatsuki and marielle are the first ones
to encounter him
episode 8. the plan is to have akatsuki
draw his attention and take him through
a gauntlet of fighters that will attack
him along the way
while they fight akotski is healed by
marielle in preparation to draw aggro
again
and drag him along to the next group
meanwhile king joe meets with lenesia
and warns her about the hazards of
deactivating the magic circle
she doesn't really [ __ ] care though
and still wants to go through with it
while they talk we learn that king joe
feels in debt to them and by extension
to shiro because the kuni clan were the
ones that were in charge of protecting
the armor and failed
but anyways back to the fighting word
marielle ends up getting frozen by ember
so akatsuki is on her own pushing
herself to go faster and faster causes
her to learn the new teaching ability
called
shadow lurk ah does zero [ __ ] damage
and she loses her sword in the process
this is pretty [ __ ] convenient
because then tatara shows up and has a
new sword for her called hakeemushi
tatara
and as it turns out her new sword also
lowers the condition of enemy weapons
that it touches
they set up the last step in their plan
and lancia deactivates the magic circle
with that down he can't teleport so
risay roots him with the freezing spell
and akatsuki destroys the sword setting
embarked free from the possession
episode nine she bro and the boys have
finally made it to the last raid boss in
lucieto of the seventh garden they're
struggling enough as
is but then two more raid bosses
ibrahibra and tatalgar join the fight
and kill everybody
when shiro dies we get a look at one of
his memories when he was just a boy both
of his parents were working so he would
sneak out and walk around at night he
was a depressed loner that would crawl
further into his shell the more people
reached out to him
this causes him to reflect on the fact
that he's been doing similar things in
this new world
also mostly by him being anti-social and
locking himself away in his room to do
work
episode 10 given the circumstances
morale amongst the raiding party is
pretty [ __ ] william gives a rousing
speech about how even though they're
social degenerates in the real world
this was their escape this game gave
them the opportunity to form bonds and
have friends instead of being complete
[ __ ] rejects
he confesses that he enjoys being stuck
in this world with his friends and he
refuses to give up on clearing this
dungeon douchebag demi cos reigns on the
parade saying that he wants to quit
anyways because they don't stand a
chance
william then starts saying that he
regrets walking out on the round table
he actually always admired shiro and was
hoping to join the debauchery tea party
before it disband this is why he was so
eager to help in the raid and was
flattered that shiro came to him
the speech raises everybody's morale and
they want to give it another shot shiro
had also come to the conclusion that he
doesn't want to keep any more secrets
from everybody in his party plus he has
a new plan for the raid and after a week
of preparations they are ready to go
back in
episode 11. during the fight it seems
that demi costa's hatred for shiro is
slowly going away
after fighting through the first stage
of the main boss shiro splits up the
group to attack the other bosses
separately
while they're fighting we get the fun
little side note that tetra is going to
be joining log horizon
right after that tall torgor joins the
fight this is all a part of the plan
though since they have positioned
themselves to avoid their field attacks
from overlapping everything is going
well enough but then mobs from lucieto
called shadow vanguard show up damikos
draws her aggro and then grabs shiro
allowing him to act as a cannon to take
them out while they run they are alone
for a second so demikos makes shiro say
his name in a way of acknowledging him
this is because up until this point
shiro had always mocked his name or made
fun of him but now he acknowledges him
and finally says his name they still
don't like each other but at least they
respect each other to a point damikos
then throws him down some steps before
luring off the pursuing mobs he had
actually led shirou to the deepest level
of the abyssal shaft which is where they
were trying to get to
inside is a chamber where all of the
world's gold is kept there is also king
joe and uru who is the abyssal chef's
final raid boss
episode 12. shiro points out that even
if he had the entire raid party with him
they still wouldn't stand a chance
against uru as per their agreement king
joe shares what he knows with shiro
this is where all golden yamato goes
when it is spent and is then
distributed to monsters when they
respond even the kuni aren't sure how
the ancient technology works but they
still protect this secret
since he had reached this place he is
given the right to take the gold
shiro then explains to kinjo that he
wanted the gold so that he could buy all
of the land
and purchasable property in yamoto
however he doesn't plan on keeping this
land he assigns
all rights to the land as well as all of
the facilities in akihabara to the
yamato server itself he had also created
and
implemented a contract that made this
transaction permanent so that nobody
else could ever buy them the gold is
then spent so it goes back into the
chamber where it started
obviously he does this so their enemies
can't purchase these zones but he also
did this because it's unfair that
adventurers can purchase
zones while people of the land can't
which could lead to problems in the
future
back to the others who defeated all the
bosses and got some nice loot out of it
shiro natsugu and tetra then returned to
akihabara after the raid was completed
silversword decided to stay in susekino
and prepare for more raids as well as to
protect the city because had also stayed
behind because he is married to an npc
there and he seems a bit happier after
the raid and fun side note just so you
know tetra is a guy now we hop on over
to plant who yaden to get the
introduction of some of their members
there is kazuhiko mizafat trudy zeldas
knacklenard quon jared gunn lori yeldon
index and finally we have kr they all
discuss the movements of the round table
members and what they're planning to do
next
and in the last scene we see that the
gang is all reunited
episode 13 has a bunch of valentine
fillers that i'm not going to cover
because they were stupid when everybody
realizes it's valentine's day it makes
shiro think back on konami konami was
the leader of the debauchery tea party
and shiro is kind of flustered when
tetra brings her name up shira then
talks with isaac about the magic circle
being deactivated isaac informs him that
there are enough high-level adventures
to deter any monster attacks and there
haven't been any player kills yet krusty
is still of course missing and misa
receives a new prosthetic arm after
losing hers when her weapon went haywire
over the narea who appeared to be the
mastermind in season one but the real
problem is index
index is the one pulling the strings
controlling the reluctant nerea
she says that her end goal is to take
over all of the yamato server
episode 14. over to minami and plant
hueyden who are progressing their
technology having made a magic circle
power train
and working on a plane kazuhiku talks
with kr who are both former debauchery
tea party members
kr says that he ran into konami in the
chinese server and apparently she is
heading for japan
after the apocalypse kr had used sole
possession to take control of a horse
and explore china to learn more about
the world that's when he came across
konami
and her party in a fight he gets him out
of trouble and the two wind up talking
she's heading for japan with her squad
including leonardo who is an assassin
from the american server
there is also coppellia a cleric that
konami had met while she was exploring
and last we have the heavy hitter elias
hackblade who is actually a level 100
blade manchester and used to be an izumo
knight
there is a filler battle where they
target an army and knolls as well as two
monsters called the sphere and pabst who
were both geniuses
but we're going to learn about geniuses
in a bit and after winning they continue
on their journey to get to japan
we see that demi costa's old strategist
lon dark had joined plant houdin and
they prepared to attack the east
episode 15. there's a concert where
isuzu plays music with toya now that
they're around level 40 shiro plans on
having the kids go on a quest for
experience and to get daz and eggs magic
bag for
inventory space then we get some pillar
content talking about how isuzu likes
music because her dad was a professional
musician or whatever but anyways
everybody's getting ready for their
quest so they go around buying new
equipment roderick also hooks them up
with a new wagon for their journey
they decide that since they're going
through four or five villages isuzu and
toya can play music at each of them like
a tour
shiro also instructs them to try and
avoid using the telepathic network so
that they can learn how to handle things
on their own
episode 16. the kids start their journey
to get to the redstone mountains they
don't keep track of how long their
summons last so when the time runs out
the horses run off forcing them to set
up camp for the night the next day they
arrive at the town of suzanne
isuzu and toyo play music at an
establishment in exchange for a free
room over to shibro who assigns
isaac with the going and training troops
and easel to level them up we also
learned that more and more ddd members
have been leaving the guild ever since
krusty's disappearance
a lot of them are joining honesty
bringing their total members to 1250 but
a lot of them are freeloaders not
contributing to the guild at all the
guild leader eins is in a bit of a
predicament because his higher ups want
him to start getting rid of members not
contributing
on the other hand he wants to keep the
number of members high so that honesty
has more influence
on the round table back over to the
noobs who come across some people of the
land being attacked by monsters so they
step in to protect them nightshade
serpents then show up and start [ __ ]
up the noobs luckily they get saved by
row 2
who looks like a female version of shiro
she's heading to the south but the
problem is that she's a vampire so she's
struggling in the sun
episode 17. we've seen rhea go off by
herself taking on her disguise as
the npc dariella meanwhile the noobs let
road 2 hang out in their wagon on their
travels to keep her out of the sun
on their way they talk about a group
called the odyssey knights who take care
of monsters in the area the noobs then
recall shiro mentioning a group called
odyssey who are obsessed with trying to
get home
row 2 explains that she's trying to get
back to ikoma to get rid of her vampire
subclass because it's a hindrance in the
daytime
back on over to shiro and the others who
discuss the growing economic disparity
in akihabara
people who hunt or develop new skills
are getting richer while those who can't
because they have the wrong skills are
barely getting by
the round table has a meaning to address
this problem eins presents some ideas on
how to combat this but all of them
involve compromising other people's
works so no decision is made the noobs
end up finding a crash carriage and some
people of the land trying to move their
cargo
nurea was actually traveling with the
people of the land saying that she was
trying to get back to minami because
they're all going the same way they
decide to help them move their cargo to
the next settlement when they end up
talking the rail learns that they're
actually students of shiro nothing
really comes from that though and then
odyssey knights from minami show up
carrying a mobile temple of boreas
the temple immediately revives any
adventurer who loses their life in its
vicinity
essentially it's a mobile cathedral but
one of the downsides to using it is that
it's said to disturb the voices of
adventurers hearts
episode 18 the other plant who yaden
members are out looking for nerea
meanwhile she's traveling with the kids
because they're all still going the same
way
they reach the town of saphil and hold
another concert we learn about a system
in place that auto translates all
conversations for adventurers allowing
them to talk without language barriers
while talking with rundle house isuzu
also learns that the people of the land
only have 42 songs that they know
and are incapable of making new ones
that's why they like her music so much
because it's something new that they
didn't know was possible
he goes on to explain that the
adventures are giving people of the land
so many new possibilities and skills
which is why so many of them are
flocking to akihabara the next day toya
talks with narea where he says that he
isn't sure about her because she's
always
forcing a smile over to shiro who notes
that nyanta has been out of touch and
their telepathy communications aren't
working the noobs are experiencing this
also
and minori speculates that it could have
something to do with the odyssey knights
mobile temple the town that they're in
is then attacked by a swarm of wyverns
in the last scene we see that nyanta is
just outside of the town which explains
why his telepathy is down also
episode 19. the odyssey knights move to
engage the wyverns they kinda turn out
to be masochists begging the wyverns to
kill them only to respawn at the mobile
temple to run in
and die again since the odyssey knights
are obsessed with getting home they
cherish every time they die because they
get to indulge in their memories
over to the planet who yate and train
where they have a new device that allows
them to summon nightshades
people of the land then control the
nightshades and earn experience while
controlling them
even if the nightshades died the npcs
are still okay
so they use it as a way to level up the
western npcs do that shades appear in
the city and attack the odyssey knights
also
after hearing how the odyssey knights
are willing to destroy some of the
buildings to fight the wyverns toya goes
and confronts one of them
he wants to try and protect the homes
because if they're destroyed the people
of the land living there won't have a
place to stay the knight just says that
he's trying to get home and doesn't care
about anything else
which procs a flashback of toya in the
real world he was in a car crash that
left him unable to walk
this led to him having a higher
appreciation of life no matter where you
are or what circumstances you're in but
the knight doesn't [ __ ] get it so he
just ignores him meanwhile nyanta
launches an assault on the plant he ate
in nightshades and lawn dark recognizes
him in the last scene
ye episode 20. meowth aboard the plant
who yaden train and is confronted by
landark the two fight with each other
and nyanta tries to get him to see that
if they attack the east they will cause
a war that will cost a lot of npcs their
lives
one dark just says he never wanted to be
in this world so he doesn't care he
starts monologuing at nyanta until
mizafa gets annoyed and she kills him
she attacks niantic next and during the
fight he goes in for the killing blow
his old friend from the tea party
kazuhiku steps in to save her from the
strike he was really just trying to
prevent nyanta from having an npc's
blood on his hands
now we hop back to narea who was shook
by toyah saying that she doesn't have to
pretend to be happy around them and she
can just be herself
she figures that this is the product of
shiro teaching him so she gets a little
bit more obsessed with shiro
rorielle finds nareya who is now
regretting letting mizafar run
rampant like this because of all the
destruction it's causing she orders
royal to kill all of the wyverns and
puts on her disguise to go look for the
children there's another short scrimmage
where mizuva attacks nyanta but kazuhiko
puts an end to that fight again
kazuhiko then informs them that he had
received orders from nereya to call off
the mission to stop nyanta from
following them kazuhiko cuts off one of
the train cars leaving him behind
over to row 2 who summons the sword
princess all quenjay who starts [ __ ]
up all of the wyverns toyah is still
bitching at the odyssey nights but
they're pretty stuck in their ways so
he's kind of wasting
his breath and then isuzu starts playing
a new song to express her hope for the
world instead of being on a
self-destructive path like the knights
episode 21. the battle of southfield
comes to an end and the next day road 2
and nareya part ways with the kids
before she goes rotu
sends a letter with the kids to give to
shiro while walking through akihabara
natsuku and akatsuki both point out how
on
edge and depressed some of the people
have been lately jiro fears that the
adventurers who are unhappy in this
world might
end up causing a war which is why he is
doing everything he can to prevent was
when members then come across an
npc with a genius title who is
constantly trying to pick up girls
when they confront him he puts curry on
under some sort of mind control
so jiro shows up and when the monster
tries to pick him up also the girls
proceed to kick the [ __ ] out of him back
to the noobs where isuzu overhears some
backlash towards the adventurers for not
being able to prevent their town from
getting messed up by the wyverns she
gets kinda down but then starts to feel
better again when she overhears all of
the people singing the song that she had
sang during the fighting and in the last
couple of scenes they get back to
akihabara and reunite with shiro and the
others
episode 22 shiro reads the letter from
row 2
where she explains that she is part of a
group known as travelers
these travelers are essential
intelligences from another world
we then see shiro go to talk to west
wind about the genius monster that they
had encountered when the girls had
attacked him he then switched forms to
fight back
these are the new form of monsters
called geniuses and he was the genius of
marriage the round table then has a
meeting to discuss these new entities
there was another genius that they had
come across
in barges who was the genius of measures
adventurous came from all over to get
items appraised by him he was
essentially hypnotizing them into
thinking that junk items were high
rarity items so that he could get more
gold when they took a raid party to
defeat him he also took on a different
form
he could manipulate their skills
distance speed damage and even their
skills targets
it wasn't looking good but then roderick
steps in and uses a magic ruler to
counteract the ability and they defeat
him
they aren't sure what to think of these
new monsters so they just assume that
they're a part of the nova sphere
pioneer expansion
afterwards shiro meets with log horizon
to discuss row 2.
row 2 was actually his second character
that he had left on the test server
this leads to him explaining that he
suspects a third party is responsible
for bringing
everybody to this world rue 2 stated in
the letter that she took over his unused
second character which was essentially
like a body without a soul and came into
this world she comes from a race of
artificially created living beings split
into two types
observers which is what row two is and
collectors
the travelers were created to collect a
valuable resource called impathions
her homeworld had ran out of this
resource which led to a rapid decline
rotu and others like her got here in
something they called the eclipse
similar to the apocalypse they aren't
sure what it was or what caused it to
happen she also explains that after
spending time with the kids she
classified them with intelligences of
rank 3 or higher
this means that they have earned the
rights to this world's resources
after that she recommended acquiring a
way to communicate with the moon because
they have a community there observing
the situation
shiro figures out if that's true then
maybe they can help the adventurers find
a way home he also
concludes that the geniuses aren't from
the nova sphere pioneer expansion but
are actually the collectors that she had
mentioned
episode 23. roderick tells shiro that
it's gonna cost a fortune to build a
lunar communication device and on top of
that it might not even work
now we hop on over to my hama where we
meet isles who is lanesya's little
brother he has grown quite fond of isaac
who is still there training easel
soldiers
sergio meets with isaac and tells him
that he's planning on making islas his
successor so he wants isaac to mentor
him while he's there
reecey and lenesia had also gone back to
my homies so that lenesia could attend
her brother's birthday party during the
party sergio presents islas as
the next one to take up the throne
westland assassins from minami then
crash the party and attempt to
assassinate islas
isaac manages to fight them all off
since they are lower levels and keeps
the boy safe
now we hop on over to reagan who was
doing some research on susukino and the
transport gates he found that the fairy
rings are related to the lunar cycles
and points out that there are actually
legends about there being elvish ruins
on the moon this makes getting in touch
with the moon
even more important reagan recommends
using the shibuya tv station which is
the only communication facility in
yamoto
and in the last couple of scenes
something starts happening and all of
the people of the land fall unconscious
episode 24. the reason all of the npcs
had passed out is because their mp had
dropped to zero and
is being constantly drained the culprits
are spirit moths and a swarm of them
attack akihabara susikino and maihama
adventurers and the royal guards start
getting targeted also
forcing everybody to retreat so ajiro
had found their nest
at the shibuya tv station which had been
turned into a dungeon called the calling
fortress
while having a discussion on what to do
about this the round table concludes
that the empathians the geniuses are
after
is actually mp everybody gets ready to
raid the station and defeat the moths at
the source before the next wave at
moonrise
when they arrive they get ambushed by
numerous monsters
during the fighting shiro is distracted
by worrying about making it back home
and not destroying the antenna on top of
the station
since he isn't completely focused on the
fighting they start getting picked apart
and forced to retreat and regroup the
kids tell shiro to pull his head out of
his ass and stop worrying about them
that gets his mindset right and to
prepare a second assault on the station
episode 25. this time around they
quickly make it to the raid boss of the
dungeon called tariq time the genius of
summoning there is a long fight scene
that i'm not going to cover but they all
work together and defeat him
now that the station is secured reagan
uses the equipment inside to try and
make contact with the moon he
inadvertently
makes contact with the china server and
to shiro's surprise kinami is the one to
answer them she had come across a
similar station and after some tinkering
she managed to get a connection also
while talking she makes him realize that
instead of just trying to get home he
should find a way to
bridge the two worlds together so that
they can live in both and another fun
side note krusty was actually
transported to the china server so he
joined up with kinami's group whoever to
plant who ye didn't work kazuhiko
suggests forming an alliance with easel
and the round table to fight the
geniuses
i'm gonna be doing the feature seasons
and you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the logo ryzen recaps in
the playlist on the right side you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing i hate more
than intros is
outros